I will most definitely add that to my
calendar hey guys how's it going today
we're gonna be chatting about the event
that is coming up this Thursday it is
another Apple event and it's titled
hello again I wish that I could be there
but I think I might have I'm awesome
missed the email invite in my email I
didn't I don't think I got it
I seen Evelyn some no message batchman
maybe I should try using different
search options I'll probably do a live
stream on Thursday so stay tuned for
that but now we're going to take a look
at some of the rumors but I think these
rumors are a little bit more than rumors
because it looks like some of these
things have been confirmed they've also
been hinted at for the past year or so
so let's just take a look I already went
and did a couple little searches but
this was probably the one that I was
most excited about because it said that
this link trademark confirms that were
getting three new MacBooks this week no
details aside from the model numbers but
the real information is there's three
new models they're looking forward to a
13 inch 15 and fingers crossed new
MacBook Air this is all extremely
exciting because I do a huge portion of
my editing on my macbook actually I was
talking with my friend Lamarr Wilson the
other day and he was saying that he
wants to go solely just MacBook just a
laptop and I was like that is definitely
something that's extremely possible
because I do most of my editing probably
maybe 70 to 80 percent on my laptop for
these types of videos I do use my desk
but most of the time I do a lot of my
video production everything is run off
of a mobile hard drive my desk guess
who's a slob me I don't know you
interview where do I put the cords even
though I have one of the trashcan Macs
that I'm using here my videos render
much faster on my macbook pro so there's
that as you can see here they're already
sort of showing this little OLED screen
and this supposedly is something that
they think that will change in regards
to what app you're using so I feel like
that's going to be kind of interesting
especially if you have maybe Spotify
even playing in the background I could
just hit next
or I don't know I'm not sure how this is
really going to work so let's see if
anybody else has any better ideas this
is awesome so this was first used in the
Macintosh 1984
my heart I'm actually getting teary-eyed
just watching this I get very emotional
look at all just click yeah click that
Mouse Oh 1984 that's when I was born
don't do the math I'm not sure if
there's any significance in the fact
that the Macintosh was born in 1984 and
I was also born in 84 and I'm just
saying so in 1998 this was saying hello
to the original iMac so 1998 I feel like
this introduction of these IMAX for me
kind of tied back to my love of Apple
and it really reiterated this is what I
love I love design I love tech I
remember watching this and was just so
excited for the future for everything
huh so I myself never had one of these
IMAX but this was one of the first
computers that we had bought my
grandmother she had the lime-green Mac I
remember going to this Apple retail
store it wasn't an Apple store because
they didn't really have those yet and if
they did have them they certainly were
not where I lived 2001 I was gonna say
1980 that was a long time ago first Mac
that I used pretty much sold in myself
even though it was my parents it was the
PowerPC it was a 6160 oh here it is oh
this is my baby
ah we definitely didn't have that
monitor that we definitely had something
different oh you changed my life
1994 Steven megahertz what Apple is
updating his macbook line because it has
to I do feel like the Mac books have
been kind of stagnant I mean they did
come out with a MacBook Air they did a
refresh fairly recently the Refresh
wasn't really enough I think to get
people to really be like alright this is
something that I need rumors say that
Apple removed the SD card slot from the
MacBook Pros which will infuriate
photographers and other people me
that SD card slot is such a lifesaver so
I'm going to be so upset if that's gone
please please don't do it and they'll
cut the MagSafe charger for us BC okay
that's fine okay it's fine if it's USBC
but you need to make it sort of magnetic
that MagSafe has saved my laptop so many
times from falling off of my desk I've
kicked that stupid Gord out of not only
my computer but so many people's
computers at coffee shops and offices
and there's going to be so much
destruction if that does if that's
that's the case no the magic tool bar oh
goodness
look at it I'm down with that but if
that kills my battery life just to have
this thing on we're gonna turn it off
immediately
what Apple introduces on Thursday will
likely be the MacBook Pro appearance
until around 2020 where is all the time
gone this looks good this looks nice I
mean it basically just looks like the
MacBook now but with that forget MacBook
Pro competition to the Microsoft Surface
is freaking awesome
I'm just saying like it's a really great
device I mean it can be a laptop when
you want it to be it can be a tablet
when you want it to be like I know this
is an Apple video at all I just I just
gotta give you a look see it's not
charged oh man like this hinge like it
just looks it's just off it's a good
looking a good looking book smells nice
too
and guess what it still has an SD card
slot please Apple don't do away with SD
card slot got it but I would have so
many dongles I'm gonna be covered in
dongles Oh Apple might notice five
things he's making one were my things
new MacBook Pro other MacBook laptop
updates new iMac oh yeah I'll take that
a 5k display I don't think they're gonna
do that but they need to they really
have to earpods launched oh that's right
holy moly oh my goodness I'm so excited
for them I've been trying recently to
wear the other headphones that come with
the the iPhone the firewire ones oh my
god if I call lightning firewire one
more time it's like my brain has just
flashed back to ten years ago
the lightning cable headphones I've been
using them a lot just to see if when I
get the air pause it's something that I
can get used to
they still don't stay in my ears very
well so I'm just I'm maybe just I think
it's just like wishful thinking like I
keep just pushing them in hoping that
maybe like my ears will conform to the
headphones you know I just maybe I need
to get surgery like I was thinking you
know maybe I could just make some calls
I do live in Los Angeles so I feel like
I could go in to somewhere and be like
listen I I need to get myself fixed up
I'm a mess my headphones to not fit in
my ear hurts oh god that sounds like
something a Kardashian would do or a
Jenner I don't know they're all the same
man this video was all over the place
extremely nostalgic for me but also very
excited for Thursday so I hope you guys
will check out the live stream I think
I'm gonna do one so make sure you guys
follow me on Twitter or Instagram or
Facebook because I will probably alert
you ahead of time not really sure how
the livestream Alerts go out here on
YouTube so I don't I can't even be like
hey stay tuned here because I don't know
if subscribers will see it or if you'll
get a notification I'm not sure if you
guys know leave me a comment below this
is completely a side note um Ryan Lochte
dog has been okay this is great this is
like the funniest thing ever I saw this
yesterday
Ryan celebrates his dog's eighth
birthday three years in a row so for the
past three years he's he said eight
years ago this handsome son was born so
that was this year and then the previous
year and then the year before that I
just hope somebody else can find humor
in that because I sent it to so many
people yesterday and I don't think
anybody else was amused as I was okay
I'll see you guys Thursday let me know
your thoughts below let me know what
you're looking forward to let me know
how you're loving your iPhone because
I'm really really loving it I also I
have found something that it does
something weird I'm not going to tell
you here because I think I need to make
a whole separate video about it because
it's it's strange and uh yeah well let's
talk about that tomorrow
I'll see you guys later bye you're
updating it gave me this little notice
that said just letting you know this is
still beta but here you go feel free to
try it out let me just tap on this
Dasani bottle and it makes everything in
the background blurry so I'm going to
take a shot and when I take this photo
is without the depth feature this is
with